if you want to learn the critical skills
that make Steve Jobs Les Brown and Gary
Vaynerchuk successful then this video is
for you it's necessary if you're going
to compete today that you look for ways
to amaze your customers if you're
willing to sort of ask a lot of
questions and think about things and
work really hard you can learn business
pretty fast
all my success has been predicated on
listening whether I'm doing it with my
ears for with my eyes
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believed and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world so to help you on
your journey today we're gonna look at
the five most important business skills
that every entrepreneur must have enjoy
coming up at number one is learn to
influence and persuade with Jordan
Belfort Lauren Hoffman was doing the
speech of Bill Gates about maybe ten
years ago and he was asked by a college
student what can we do as students to
make ourselves more valuable in the
workplace
so you think Warren Buffett would say
learn how to pick stocks learn how
investments you know whatever he would
say not what he says he says go out and
take a course in sales and conservation
day he did Dale Carnegie change his life
there you go now that point because he
took they said I took Dale Kearney
changement without that you don't he'd
be without that course yeah he'd be the
richest money manager in Omaha Nebraska
then no one ever heard of yeah Annie met
his wife that way the love is like
because without the ability to influence
and persuade yeah okay
you can't put yourself out there into
the world and be known for what you
really are number two is amaze your
customers with Les Brown this is a
customer driven economy it's necessary
for you to always explore various ways
in which you can improve the quality of
service that you're providing for the
people in your organization I remember
something a major company had talked
about the extra value service they were
providing for their customers and the
lady who had the news conference
summarized it this way she said it's not
our intention to satisfy our customers
or to please our customers our intention
is to amaze
it's necessary if you're going to
compete today that you look for ways to
amaze your customers by being one of
those individuals that keep your
commitments they keep your word that's
relentless it's necessary you work with
the people that you bring into all your
organization but they see that you are a
good example of a person to work with
because you model integrity and
determination and ambition and truth and
honesty and the way in which you conduct
business
number three is articulate your vision
clearly with kevin O'Leary it turns out
in corporate America today and I teach
this now you know I've taught at Notre
Dame and MIT the graduating cohorts I
explain this to them when you're leading
when you want to be a leader you have to
articulate your idea in 90 seconds or
less you have to explain why you're the
right person to lead and above all you
have to know your numbers you can see it
happen on Shark Tank it works in the
real world - - and frankly Shark Tank is
the real world because it's real capital
so I use that and I teach it and I think
everybody should think about that
explaining your vision clearly
succinctly in a short period of time is
up being really important number four is
have a plan with Daymond - a business
plan got a lot of business that doesn't
exist is a lot because you can't you
can't say like who do your facts based
on because it hasn't happened yet you
can't really determine who's going by
what and how much this cost sell you
can't say I'm gonna make a million this
year there's not gonna be a rash you
know what what I'll do was put together
what it's like a script I put together
how we make the goods I'm gonna market
the goods
how much Justin buy the goods we have
with my margin and then when I'm gonna
sell it and
I'm going to put back into the business
and how much I will put in my pocket you
know if that kind of thing you know I
write things that like if you look look
one put that on the wall right there
right if you see you see a piece of
paper while I don't want it that's it I
got to do you know I like to put things
on the wall I can't even know what I've
got to do I need to look at it and
across it up I don't consider that a
business plan per se or but I have a
plan you know I'm saying like I have a
plan plus you want other people to
understand the plan because you can't do
anything on your own so you want to be
able to articulate it to them away they
understand and that they can look back
because I've talked quick and like you
said a lot of times I say [ __ ] you like
I didn't understand that I need to tell
you later
yeah you know so you want to have
something someone can keep looking at
and they could see you crossing it off
and then they can kind of get it by
absorbing fault you know by watching
what you're doing
number five is question everything with
Steve Jobs throughout the years in
business I found something which was I
always ask why you do things and the
answers you invariably get are oh that's
just the way it's done
nobody knows why they do what they do
nobody thinks about things very deeply
in business that's what I found I'll
give you an example when we were
building our Apple ones in the garage we
knew exactly what they cost when we got
into a factory in the Apple two days the
accounting had this notion of a standard
cost where you'd kind of set a standard
cost and then at the end of a quarter
you'd adjust it with a variance and I
kept asking why did we do this and the
answer was well that's just the way it's
done and after about six months of
digging into this what I realized was
the reason you do it is because you
don't really have good enough controls
to know how much it costs so you guess
and then you fix your guess at the end
of the quarter and the reason you don't
know how much it cost is because your
information systems aren't good enough
so but nobody said it that way and so
later on when we designed this automated
Factory for Macintosh we were able to
get rid of
a lot of these antiquated concepts and
know exactly what something costs to the
second so in business a lot of things or
I call it folklore they're done because
they were done yesterday and the day
before and so what that means is is if
you're willing to sort of ask a lot of
questions and think about things and
work really hard you can learn business
pretty fast that's not the hardest thing
in the world not rocket science it's not
rocket science No
now I've got a special bonus clip with
casein Einstein and Gary Vaynerchuk but
before getting to that the question of
the day today is which of these five
skills are your weakest what's the one
that you need to improve on the most
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your when where it
is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus
this is gonna blow away people
especially your fanbase listening you
know I speak a lot and I talk over
people and I'm loud and intense but all
of my success has been predicated on
listening whether I'm doing it with my
ears for with my eyes still I use a
probably communication which I think
you're building on what Garrett said I
think communication is - a two-way
street but being able to articulate and
communicate what it is that I'm trying
to communicate is something that I find
I focus on all day long every time I
speak
one wrong move yeah the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]